avec nous Hélène buzetti Michel David
Christian Dufour bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir c'est sûr que
passer de ce sujet là à la campagne au
Québec les gens vont dire bon déjà que
monsieur Legault dit aujourd'hui bon ben
savez-vous je suis prêt à collaboré avec
les chefs de position c'est comme
c'était réglé
l'élection au Québec je vais vous faire
entendre
pour nous remettre dans cette dans ce
sujet monsieur Legault madame Anglade et
Gabriel ado Dubois puis on revient tout
de suite
je vais travailler avec tout le monde là
qui est de bonne foi faire avancer le
Québec
c'est pas son style de leadership celui
de la collaboration il veut nous imposer
ses idées il veut pas collaborer
François Legault
n'a pas démontré dans son premier mandat
de volonté de travailler avec les autres
partis politiques sur la question de
l'environnement
tous les parties ont des bonnes idées là
c'est pas ça la question la question
c'est qu'on a des choix de société à
faire et ce que nous propose la CAQ
c'est une résignation sur plein de
questions fondamentales comme les
changements climatiques l'avenir du
français puis le statut national du
Québec dans le monde
moi je prêterai travailler avec tout le
monde c'est pour faire avancer les
intérêts du Québec je sais que tu sais
j'ai évidemment je suis pas toujours
idéologiquement d'accord avec tout le
monde puis il y a des gens aussi qui
sont pas toujours d'accord avec moi
très bien alors
pourquoi monsieur Legault était si
confiant je vous montre le dernier
sondage Léger publié dans le Journal de
Montréal ce matin 37 % monsieur Legault
oui une petite baisse du bois est à 17
avec Québec solidaire 16 15 et 15 le
Parti québécois est en fait le seul
mouvement
monsieur LEGO a baissé un peu depuis le
tout début mais Paul
saint-pierre-flamondon plus deux donc
une montée de 4,5 depuis le début
Hélène bon tour de table comment vous
avez vu cette journée ça ressemblait à
la dernière journée de campagne où la
première d'un nouveau régime oui bah
écoutez ce sondage là il est
réconfortant pour monsieur Legault parce
que 37% oui c'est une baisse vous l'avez
mentionné mais ça équivaut exactement au
score qu'il avait obtenu à la dernière
élection donc ça semble être un peu dans
la poche mais il y a une tendance
baissière qui doit l'inquiéter un peu je
pense qu'il est content que la campagne
tire à sa fin et le plus grand risque
probablement pour la CAQ c'est que cette
élection se transforme à une élection
sur quelle est votre deuxième meilleur
choix qui voudriez vous voir dans le
poste de l'opposition officielle et que
plein de gens qui voteraient peut-être
pour laque prennent tellement pour
acquis que la carte va rentrer qui
pourrait peut-être dire bah finalement
je vais voter pour le PQ ou pour un
autre parti et donc Monsieur Le Gaulois
conclure le deal comme on dit et je
pense que c'est un peu ça sa stratégie
aujourd'hui de dire je vais collaborer
aux autres c'est pour peut-être apaiser
ceux qui ont la crainte de la superbe
majorité voilà voilà n'ayez pas capable
je vais collaborer avec tous mais
oubliez pas de voter pour moi quand même
très bien Michel David oui bon
c'est dans la poche mais il y a un
réflexe qui est possible et qui est oui
mais pas trop fort à partir du moment où
il est acquis que le gouvernement va
être celui de la CAQ que les libéraux
vont perdre des plumes ça veut dire
qu'il va pas mal plus de députés kakis
que la dernière fois elle aurait
beaucoup de gens qui vont dire bon ben
attention à la regarde et c'est un
danger qui guette sérieusement je pense
laque maintenant la collaboration tout
le monde sait que c'est un peu bidon là
il y a dans un dans notre système quand
le gouvernement est majoritaire la
collaboration à l'état à son strict
minimum et monsieur Legault je pense que
les parties de position raison de se
méfier il y a pas démontrer beaucoup
beaucoup de d'envies de de partager quoi
que ce soit même pendant la pandémie
vous savez les réunions entre les chefs
ils disaient tous dans le fond il ne dit
pas grand chose il fait vraiment le
moins qui peut alors je pense qu'en bout
de ligne
il va probablement avoir quelque part
autour de 90 côtés mais pour beaucoup de
gens c'est beaucoup ça oui Christian
c'est facile
une semaine avant le commencement
officielle puisque comme si l'élection
aurait pas lieu lundi
se passer dans les derniers jours il y a
des gens dont je fais partie qui se
décide souvent très très tard c'est un
combat la politique le combat est pas
fini moi j'en reviens pas qu'on parle de
collaboration maintenant d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être avec j'en reviens pas à
quel point il y a beaucoup de gens
autour de moi des amis que j'aime bien
qui ont pas de raison en fait de pas
aller voter lundi mais qui ont voté par
anticipation prenons c'est fini mais moi
je peux être ancien mais une campagne
plus belle prédiction vous soudez
Patrice lorsque vous aviez reçu Monsieur
mouchoir en entrevue lors du centième
anniversaire de René des Belges tout le
monde intérêt pour le saint-pierre mon
nom tout le monde regardait le PQ de
haut regardez où est-ce qu'on en est
actuellement donc ça va finir lundi ils
appellent à la collaboration c'est
vraiment vraiment
c'est comme un électrochent
était a marqué le début de la remontée
du Parti québécois comme ça avait
fouetté les gens quand même on laissera
pas ok mais je veux pas ouvrir ça
parce que c'est très juste
c'est dangereux pour ericain
forcément la nouvelle saveur du jour
c'est pas le saint-pierre
de circonscription
autrement dit c'est vraiment pas fini ça
continue à se dérouler les gens qui ce
qui est fini c'est dans Camille lorrain
hier on a moins eu le temps d'en parler
j'étais à Québec hier comme vous savez
et dans Camille lorrain madame Marie-Eve
Rancourt qui s'est désisté après avoir
on va peut-être voir les images là elle
a elle a déposé son pamphlet de Québec
solidaire puis alors oups pris celui du
PQ elle a amené avec elle
bon
erreur de jugement avait dit le chef
elle-même madame Rancourt avait dit
erreur de jugement là et par elle n'est
plus elle ne sera plus fait son nom
d'ailleurs est-ce que on bifle son nom
Hélène ou oui ce qu'on me dit c'est que
ceux qui ont déjà voté et d'ailleurs je
vous laisse sauter là-dessus sur ce que
Christian disait c'est ça un peu le
risque du vote par anticipation ceux qui
ont déjà voté pour cette dame lors de
l'élection
par voie anticiper et ben leur vote est
un peu perdu et ce qu'on nous dit c'est
que en remettant les bulletins de vote
aux électeurs on leur mentionne que
cette candidature là n'existe plus parce
que elle sera apparemment sur certains
bulletins mais moi je pense que le grand
gagnant de tout ça évidemment c'est pas
le saint-pierre-plamondon c'était une
course à quatre lors de la dernière
élection
l'abandon de la candidate solitaire
augmente énormément les chances de du PQ
et j'aurai le goût de pastiché un peu le
slogan du camp du OUI en 1995 et dire
oups et ça devient possible je pense que
tout d'un coup l'élection du chef
béquiste devient un scénario très posé
je trouve que Québec solidaire quand
même le chef Gabriel nado Dubois a quand
même une belle posture dans cette chose
dans cette histoire parce qu'il a tout
de suite pris une décision très très
radicale en expulsant la candidate ou en
tout cas je vais venir là-dessus mais
restons sur Paul Saint-Pierre parce que
je vais vous demander si c'était pas
exagéré que quelqu'un quitte là je vous
avertis je vous demande ça mais juste
avant restons c'est comme si là il
recevait le vent tourner et même
l'improbable une anecdote dans dans la
circonscription de la candidat du Québec
solidaire profite Michel David à Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon c'est quand même
fou là c'est un cadeau du ciel pour
Monsieur Saint-Pierre de La Mondon parce
que jusqu'à présent ça sa réélection
discutait très problématique pour le
moins maintenant quand on regarde les
sondages bon les agrégations je m'en
méfie un peu mais il y avait un
manuscrit là il y a la semaine dernière
la marge est quand même assez grandes
c'était agréable à 11 points différents
entre le député kakis sortant et
Monsieur Saint-Pierre la Mondon mais il
y a quand même 19 points à peu près de
d'intention de vote au Québec solidaire
alors la question évidemment c'est où
est-ce que ça va aller quand on regarde
les deuxièmes choix il est clair que
c'est le PQ qui est avantageux je pense
que 40 près de 45% des électeurs
solidaires ont le PQ comme deuxième
choix et là ils vont devoir manifester
leur deuxième choix ou il reste à la
maison parce que
ils veulent pas boiter pour qui que ce
soit d'autre il y a une animosité entre
le PQ etqs qui qui comprenait bien mais
je pense que depuis le début de la
campagne beaucoup d'électeurs de QS ont
trouvé quand même que Monsieur
Saint-Pierre à Mondon était était était
finalement contrairement à Jean-François
lisez la dernière fois j'étais beaucoup
d'hostilités c'est pas le cas de
Monsieur Saint-Pierre de Mondon ouais
Christian un petit mot là-dessus sur le
ce retour du sort
c'est comme si les astres étaient
alignés en faveur de Paul Saint-Pierre
flamandon puis aussi c'est toute une
ironie Quebec solidaire qui est le parti
vertueux par excellence le parti
d'honneur de leçon que c'est celui qui
font qui est pris vraiment les culottes
ben c'est et puis ça met les projecteurs
sur Paul Saint-Pierre plein monocalypse
découvre et je radote ce que j'ai dit
tantôt c'est la nouvelle saveur du jour
avait découvert Jack Clinton donc c'est
intéressant c'est pas terminé et pour
les autres c'est inquiétage je peux
savoir aller bon sang quelque chose
restez avec nous vous prenez ma mauvaise
habitude de bouger un peu
que j'ai bon mais marié Franco elle
devait vraiment
se désister Hélène Michel et Christian
oui c'est une erreur de jugement
évidemment je peux en train de dire que
c'est rien de mais est-ce que ça valait
la peine suprême de dire je ne serai
plus candidat de Michel mais à partir du
moment où c'est un acte criminel c'est
salaire fou de dire simplement prendre
un pamphlet mais voler quelque chose
dans une boîte à lettres apparemment
c'est considéré comme un accliminel mais
au-delà de ça et Christian le bien dit
l'être QS c'est le parti donneur de
leçon qui qui depuis le début prétend
faire la politique autrement alors là ce
Saint-Pierre de Mondon je pense vous
pouvez pas vraiment passer l'éponge
là-dessus donc Hélène vous êtes d'accord
elle pouvait pas dire je m'excuse j'ai
vraiment j'ai fait une grave erreur de
jugement je suis désolé les électeurs
décideront moi je trouve qu'elle avait
de l'air très très habile dans son geste
je me demande si elle le fait vraiment
juste une fois bon oui je pense je pense
que je veux pas accuser quoi que ce soit
mais je l'ai trouvé quand même très
habile
je pense que c'était la bonne chose à
faire et c'est pour ça que je dis que
Gabriel nanaud Dubois je crois c'est
bien comporté à transformer la situation
en se donnant un peu de hauteur et je
veux juste rappeler
l'année dernière à l'élection fédérale
un député libéral dans Calgary qui a
fait exactement la même chose le seul la
seule différence c'est que la vidéo est
sortie juste après le jour de vote et là
il y a je suis désolé il y avait des
erreurs d'information ce qui n'était pas
vrai et il est encore libéral lui il est
encore dans le caucus de Monsieur
Trudeau mais on le pressentait comme
ministre parce qu'il était le seul élu à
Calgary et il n'a pas accédé au cabinet
encore libéral mais pas ministre une
erreur de jugement
parce qu'autant sur le plan politique
c'est vrai que c'est une erreur que les
conséquences mais moi ça me stresse son
genre en fait sur le plan humain parce
que dans un premier temps je te choqué
comme tout le monde hier soir je
repensais à ça je veux juste quand même
anecdote
j'avais prévu la caméra là
mais sur le plan humain sur le plan
humain
on n'arrête pas de parler de
l'importance de rembourser le le combat
public et là voici quelqu'un qui est
même pas capable de l'accepter un
dépliant assez parlée
politique c'est pas de ça dont je parle
c'est comme citoyen qui vit dans une
société ou de plus en plus de caméras ou
nos comportements sont observés moi
quand j'étais jeune il y avait des
péchés véniels des péchés mortels on
était catholiques
je vous arrête je vous aime beaucoup
mais je vous arrête
troisième lien le criait pas Christian
troisième lien oui on va en reparler
on va écouter monsieur Legault tien on
va on va écouter monsieur Legros qui se
fait questionner pour la
34e journée de suite sur les études
rendues publiques pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas tout de suite pourquoi attendre on
écoute
on a toujours depuis quatre ans été
transparent puis on va continuer d'être
transparent
la pandémie des que l'étude sur un
tunnel 4 voies centre-ville à
centre-ville c'est quand des impacts de
la pandémie entre autres sur le
télétravail dès qu'elle va être
complétée à votre rendu public
bon Michel c'est comme le caillou dans
son soulier le monsieur Legault puis ils
écoutaient lâchez-moi avec les études
elles sont plus bonnes il faut les
refaire parce que les données que nous
avons parce que il n'y pas qu'à des
données dont notre journaliste parlait
plutôt c'est donner là son dépassé donc
je dois en refaire d'eau là est-ce que
c'était la meilleure posture à partir du
moment où il a répondu au début ce qui
était pris pour faire 32 jours il aurait
pu aller plus loin d'après
monsieur Legault je pense à tout fou dès
le départ c'est à dire que c'est vrai
que le projet est pas le même mais les
données de base sont les mêmes c'est à
dire qu'il y a autant de monde à les
vies le quel que soit le projet qu'on va
adopter est-ce que ça va être 4 voix 6
voix un tunnel 2 tunnel l'important
c'est le nombre de personnes qui vont
traverser et ça apparemment dans les
études qui ont déjà été réalisées et que
le gouvernement a en sa possession on a
cette réponse là alors ça sert à rien de
faire un pont un tunnel ou n'importe
quoi s'il y a pas de monde alors
l'important c'est d'abord de décider
s'il faut faire un troisième lien et
Monsieur LEGO a décidé lui que oui ça en
prenait un peu importe ce que disent les
études alors moi je vois pas comment
Monsieur Lego peut d'une manière ou
d'une autre présenter sa version des
faits comme quelque chose d'acceptable
parce que tant que le projet on sait
même pas si nécessaire peu importe le
projet il dit c'est comme si il se dit
on met ça dans le passif les Hist
d'études je vais peut-être perdre
quelques votes mais ça va être plus
compliqué si jamais je rendais publique
les données que nous avons ce que vous
êtes Hélène où est probablement ceci dit
je n'embarque pas nécessairement dans le
dans la version des parties adverses qui
disent il a menti je pense que depuis le
début il nous dit que Huawei y a des
études mais il veut pas nous les rendre
public parce qu'elle ne correspond plus
exactement à ce qu'il a en tête alors je
pense que les deux ne sont pas
incohérents là cette étude peut exister
monsieur Lego peut ne pas avoir menti
quand elle existence d'études bon on est
encore là je n'ai pas vu le contenu des
études alors je sais pas je suis pas
spécialiste dans ce domaine là je ne
sais pas quel point les conclusions ou
de cette étude là peuvent s'appliquer
aux nouveaux projets qui est encore
juste dans la tête de quelques kakis je
pense que fondamentalement le problème
de base de toute cette histoire c'est
que on n'a jamais eu la première initi
la première étude celle de base qui nous
dirait qu'elles sont les besoins de
déplacement dans cette région ou
serait-il optimal de créer un troisième
lien si un besoin pour un troisième lien
ce constat de base qui doit venir avant
la sélection d'un tunnel d'un pont à
gauche à droite à l'Ouest à l'Est sont
pas vue c'est un peu la charrue et le la
charrue et le beurre
vous avez un côté romantique vous
aimeriez que tous on soit en cœur pour
un grand projet de société au Québec un
bon tunnel mais les gens demandent des
chiffres en fait
je n'en reviens pas il faut vraiment
qu'on soit une société privilégiée quand
on pense c'est vos femmes en Iran pas
l'Ukraine pour se faire des semaines
qu'on radote là dessus la cause est
entendue on peut pas dire que François
Legault a été transcendant
extraordinaire parce que ça change qu'on
apprend aujourd'hui on le sait que
monsieur Legault est brouillons et c'est
pas vrai parce que je me suis jamais dit
que j'étais pour le troisième bien mais
je constate que quel que soit le grand
projet collectif au Québec on va avoir
de la misère à le réaliser parce qu'on
est bien bon pour critiquer puis
débattir mais pour le reste on en parle
encore aujourd'hui pas très envie on en
parle encore on va en parler jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à samedi parlez à Monsieur
Kader de la Formule 1 puis des
strictement nez oui il y a une dynamique
là-dedans qui s'installe mais plus on
apprend un détail ou deux plus ça refait
tourner la roue bon ok c'est terminé
les professionnels de l'information s'y
intéressent mais le vrai monde
qui va pas assez vite c'est terminé
l'émission est terminée au revoir à
bientôt à